events I will try to make up for the
Last Time by going quickly over this
material about enumeration uh
algorithms various circuits and their
use in query
evaluation I'm Anto Mar from Telecom
Paris by the
way um so let me give you a brief
introduction to why um why we want to do
this in mostly for database people and
database Theory people this talk is
about the approach of intentional query
evaluation where we have a query we have
a database and instead of evaluating the
query directly on the database we will
compile the query on the database to
some circuit in a tractable class of
circuits like those with the weird names
dsdn NFS UOB bdds and so on this is also
called grounding the query on the data
it's related to Computing the provence
of the query on the data and then we
will use this circuit to retrieve the
answer that we were interested in
originally we have seen on Monday uh
with two great Talks by by Dan and Mikel
how to use the intentional career
evaluation approach for tasks like
counting weighted counting and
probability computation today or at
least this morning for my talk we're
going to use this intentional approach
for something else for enumeration of
query answers
okay so I will cover some preliminaries
and state the problem a bit more
formally and then most of my talk will
be spent on the question of efficient
enumeration for circuits in a specific
class so ddn andf set circuits indeed
unlike weighted counting or probability
computation it's not so clear how do you
even Define enumeration with circuits
and how do you get efficient en
numeration results for circuits so this
is what I'll be presenting to you and
then I will tell you how these results
for enumeration on circuits can be used
for career evaluation and other such
applications this is Joint work with a
bunch of people uh some of which are in
the in the room some of which have been
present during the the Simons program so
bis who is here Stan Mel Mel is here
also Mar mat and chrisan and it's been
done in a series of papers so we of
papers so we started at IAL 2017 this
approach with the result on circuits and
it's application to monic second order
query evaluation then we've mostly
focused on monic second order queries on
trees under updates that I will talk
more about and monic second queries
onwards in the framework of document
spanners
which I also talk about and more
recently we've been extending this to
weiro queries like annotated grammars on
on text and uh very recently a few weeks
ago uh ranked enumeration for
Mantic okay so what's nice about giving
these kind of talks at Simon's Institute
program is that at least for those of us
who've been here since the beginning of
the program
yes
oops
[Music]
right so yeah I will reveal that this is
from this has been covered in noar EC
talks at the September Workshop so
enumeration algorithms are a way to
measure the complexity of tasks where
it's not just a decision problem like
yes or no but the problem is to compute
an answer set which is very large and so
you need to change a bit the complexity
measure because just writing down the
answer writing down the output takes up
so much time so we do this by splitting
the computation into two phases so given
the input say a database and we want to
compute some query results we have a
first phase which called the
preprocessing phase or the indexing
phase uh that ideally runs in linear
time in the input not always possible
but this is the best we can hope for and
comput from the data some representation
that makes it easier to compute the
query answers the index input or so you
can think of this as a compressed
version of the of the answers to produce
or a factorized repres ation of the
answers or some pre-index version of the
database whatever and then you have a
second phase the enumeration phase that
takes this and must produce all of the
results we're interested in without
duplicates as efficiently as possible
and here efficiently would mean each
result is produced in linear time in the
size of this result so if the results to
produce have constant size uh we would
want each result to be produced in
constant time independent from the size
of the database so I mean probably most
of you have seen this stuff before but
if you have not uh this is a rather
strong guarantee like if if you want to
compute a query where the answers have
size four like some constant I give you
a database and you have a delay that it
is a constant that depends on four but
like four is a constant also so there is
a certain number of operations and every
that every like say 100 every 100
operations you just produce a new result
and this 100 bound holds must hold no
matter what's the size of the of the
input database can be extremely large
doesn't matter you have a constant time
a constant time guarantee and so once
you produced the first result you store
a state and then you call the
enumeration algorithm again with that
state and must produce the next result
change the state Etc until we reach a
special state that says enumeration has
concluded and must be the case and then
you have received all all the answers to
your query normally uh many of you have
seen this already this is the context in
which I'll be working so for this
enumeration problem now knowledge
compulation
again he and H Jing talks at the boot
camp have covered this I'm not going to
I I'm going to introduce the dnf of
course don't worry but I want to tell
you about this General approach to
knowledge compilation which we think is
a is a is a great modular way to get
enumeration results or other kinds of
results this is at the left you have the
world without knowledge before knowledge
compulation was invented people would
toil like for each of these various
problems represented with like three
different colors people would carefully
design a specific enumeration algorithm
for each
problem and we propose with the
knowledge compilation
approach each problem you will instead
compile to a circuit the idea of the
drawing is that designing an enumeration
algorithm is complicated because you
need to understand things about both qu
evaluation and also design the design of
efficient numeration algorithms messy
data structures and so on here you have
less gears so it's supposed to be
simpler just translate your query
evaluation problem into a circuit in a
specific class and then completely
forget about queries databases and so on
just have a circuit the class in which
the circuit folds the kind of invariant
that's supposed to make your life easier
afterwards and then you just need one
enumeration result saying on circuits of
class blah dsdn NF whatever you can do
efficient enumeration and then these
results are obtained by the prod
combining these results with that result
at least that's the theory but this is
the appro that we wanted to to um
investigate with this um enumeration um
like knowledge B knowledge compilation
based
enumeration let me now present to you
the circuit formalism that we use
unfortunately and this is the this is
the theory in practice in each paper you
end up introducing a circuit formalism
that might be a bit different from what
exists before so it's like it it doesn't
plug in as nicely as you would want but
uh you will probably recognize these
circuits as being related to the ddn NFS
we've been hearing so much about in
previous talks so hope hopefully this
will not be too shocking so these we
call set circuits because they're not
really Boolean circuits but they are a
concise way to represent sets of
assignments so let me Define them to you
a set circuit is a dag of vertices
called Gates you have an output gate
which is where we're going to get the
result of the circuit we have variable
Gates which don't have any input and
stand for variable as well we have
constant Gates uh true and false
basically and then we have internal
Gates product and Union okay this is
going to be cartisian product this is
going to be set Union I will explain the
semantics afterwards but so people
familiar with circuits might recognize
them people familiar with factorized
databases might might see this as a bit
familiar this is a kind of abstract
verion of factorized
database what about the semantics each
gate captures a set of assignments so
it's just a set of sets but because set
of sets is confusing the inner sets I
will always call them assignments
so this is defined inductively a
variable gate captures one assignment
and the assignment captures one what
contains just that variable okay a singl
ton
assignment the true Gates capture one
assignment which is the empty assignment
the false gate do not capture any
assignments and the two combination
Gates the product Gates and the union
Gat so the product gate is doing a kind
of relational product or cartisan
product it captures assignments in in
the following way it's all the
combinations of an assignment captured
by the first input and an assignment
captured by the second input let's say
the product Gates always have two inputs
or at most two inputs so you get that so
in the example you see here sing Single
empty assignment time Singleton
assignment X gives Singleton assignment
X single turn X time single y gives
single one assignment XY yes do we think
of the incess or assignments as two
poles
um so the assignments you could think of
them as tup but they are really just
sets if you wanted to see them as tupes
you would want your variables not to be
variables but to be a pair of an
attribute name and a domain
element X in in a database setting in a
factorized database setting that these
would be things saying uh colum a
contains value a well contain colon a
contains value B if that makes
sense but if you don't care about Factor
databases to or whatever this is just a
way to a complicated way to represent a
set of sets that's
it Union Gates do the union of the
captured sets of their inputs okay so
here this circuit captures two
assignments X and
XY so if you're familiar with arithmetic
circuits you might recognize uh
something that you like here because I
could see this as an arithmetic Circuit
by saying uh this is is the constant
zero this is the constant one and this
would be just the product of uh the
captured polinomial and this would be
the the sum of the captured polinomial
right a set of sets you can see it as a
polinomial so let me also reveal that
people who like semi Rings might
recognize something that they enjoy the
N ofx semi ring you can see a set of
sets here as a polinomial like a
monomial is a set well one with a with
with without higher degrees than one a
monomial would be would be just a set of
variables and a polinomial would be a
sum of monomials okay so a set of of
sets of variables in some sense and this
then would correspond to sum and this
then would correspond to
product the task that we want to solve
is enumerating the assignments captured
by uh a gate uh the output gate of the
circuit in particular so for instance
here we would want to enumerate first X
and then we would want to enumerate XY
of course if the assignments are large
we can spend linear time writing down
the assignment linear time in the size
of that assignment but
uh we not going to work with arbitary
set circuits but with restricted set
circuits so ddn andf set circuits Union
Gates must be deterministic meaning the
inputs are disjoint no assignment is
captured by two input so this is taking
a disjoint Union of the input
Gates and the times are decomposed
posable meaning no variable has a path
to two different inputs uh times are
taking the times of two subcircuits on
this on this joint set of variables so
like in the inner Union when doing the
relational products you do not have
duplicates
right and what is the result then so the
result is that we can enumerate
efficiently the satisfying assignments
of circuits of this form so given a ddn
andf set circuit we can enumerate the
captured assignments with linear time PR
thing and output linear DeLay So delay
linear image
assignment we also have a part of this
result if you're only interested in
results of assignments of a constant
size so for instance you only want small
assignments or you're working with
queries in data complexity and the size
of assignments can be assumed to be
constant then the delay can be constant
delay maybe you don't care like me about
set circuits and so you wonder okay this
is very nice but why do do I care about
the DN andf set circuits where do you
want where can you find these in the
wild well two possibilities either
intentional query evaluation tasks so
you want to evaluate a query on a
database and you will trans you will
compile it into a ddn andf set circuits
I will tell you later that this is
possible or if you want to start with a
Boolean circuit you have a Boolean
circuit at dnf in the usual sense of
boan circuits you can convert them
actually to ddn andf set circuits it's
just that ddn andf set circuits are
simpler to work with for for the for the
proofs but if you have a regular Boolean
ddn andf you can convert it the only
catch is that the conversion is not
linear time in general so if you have a
ddn NF that's without additional
assumptions converting it to ddn andf
set circuits might take quadratic time
yes so it seems that there really zero
supressed decision
diagram missing false CD would you
directly yes so you have correctly
guessed what is the mismatch in the two
semantics indeed you can see these set
circuits as a zero supressed version of
a of a of of a diagram or of a circuit
and so the the reason why we need to do
this the reason why the time is
quadratic is because we need the ddn NF
to be smooth which can take quadratic
time to enforce and once it is smooth
then the the two semantics don't matter
but if it is not smooth then indeed the
difference in semantics is that with
normal Boolean circuits when you don't
talk about a variable it means it can be
true or false it doesn't matter right
whereas with the set circuit if I don't
talk about the variable then it's not in
the answers so it's basically implicitly
assumed implicitly enforced to be false
this is why there we have this this
whole problem so if the ddn NF is smooth
then you can do the conversion in linear
time if the DDF is structured you can do
the conversion in linear time not
because we can really do smoothing but
because we can cheat so we can we can do
implicit smoothing in linear time and
get a ddn andf set circuits except it
has some additional special Gates
standing for range of variables and for
which enumeration also works so I'm
going to sweep this under the rug
because I don't want to mess up my
circuit formalism with this
consideration but remember that if you
just work with bull if you want to use
this as I have bullan circuits I want to
do eneration you want your Boolean
circuits to be ddn NFS and to be smooth
and if they are not smooth but
structured you can maybe enforce it
nevertheless or you can pay quadratic
time and then you can do the enumeration
right so I will tell you a bit about how
this result is proved and then I will
tell you about the
applications so the proof consists of
two phases the pre-processing phase and
the enumeration phase and the
pre-processing phase is split into two
steps first I will normalize the circuit
to basically eliminate messy things that
are going to make my life harder and
then I will index it uh with some to
make it to make it easier to enumerate
based on the normalized circuit and then
once once we have the normalized circuit
that that has been indexed we do this
enumeration
Phase Linear in each result and we
produce the results so I will explain to
you what is inside these two boxes but
before that I will explain to you what
is inside that box because I think it's
easy to get an intuition of how
numeration works so I'm going to give
you a a wrong version of this box that's
easy to understand and then I will fix
it by explaining why we need to put
things into these two boxes so this is
the the easy but wrong Story how do we
do numeration for ddn andf set circuits
well let's do an induction base cases I
have a variable I want to enumerate the
satisfying assignments well I enumerate
the one assignment and I
stop induction case I have a union gate
how do I do I want to enumerate the
assignments captured by this gate well I
enumerate the capture assignments by
recursing on the first input and then I
numerate the satisfying assignments by
recursing on the second input if I have
more inputs and I recurse on all of the
successive inputs and I just produce the
assignments for this one and then this
one Etc do I get
duplicates no because it's a ddn NF so
this Union is disjoined so each
assignment is produced by one
input times gate Let's do an induction
inductive case to well let's recurse in
G en numerate the satisfying assignments
all of the captured assignments sorry
and for each assignment let's combine it
with all of the assignments to the right
so just do like two nested for Loops for
each captured assignment of this gate
for each captured assignment of that
gate output the
concatenation does this pose problems of
like a variable occurring both here and
here and get occurring twice when we do
the concatenation it does not thanks to
decomposability
no duplicate variables the variables
here and here are
disjointed okay so that concludes my
talk not really so I have swept some
problems uh so the first problem is
handling the empty set if you think of
an arithmetic circuit this is basically
I have zero and so some gates evaluate
to zero and I cannot waste time with
them take this circuit this set circuit
here this captures the empty set when I
do the product it also captures the
empty set when I do the product it also
captures the empty set and so it could
be the case that large parts of my
circuit are actually capturing the empty
set because I'm just multiplying them
with something that's empty and if I
spend time in this inductive proof here
going down parts of the circuits that
turn out to be empty then this is
messing up my delay guarantee I do not
want this to happen right fortunately I
have linear time preprocessing and in
the linear time preprocessing I can
normalize to just get rid of these parts
of the circuit that I'm not interested
in and this is in fact completely
straightforward just compute bottom up
for each gate whether it captures
something or not it's completely
completely trivial to do this in linear
time and then just get rid of the parts
of the circuit that don't cap cap
anything so you will not be tempted to
go into them that's the normalization
step there is a second problem that we
need to address in the normalization
step which is the case of the empty
assignment in arithmetic circuit terms
this is multiplying by one if you
multiply by one too many times then you
can you can have big parts of the
circuit that are just doing
multiplications by one and not making
any progress so taking this x time mty
assignment gives you X time mty
assignment gives you X gives and so on
if you recurse into that gate and you
need to go down all of this chain to
finally get the variable X then your
delay is not going to be linear in the
size of what you find at the bottom
you're going to to waste too much time
going down these things so we have to
simplify this stuff away as
well to do this we do what's called
homogeneization uh meaning we split we
each gate between two copies one gate
which is only taking charge of the empty
assignment and the other gate which is
taking charge of the non-mt assignments
and we re we we change the wires to wire
gates in the right way so that we can
distinguish the empty and nonm
assignments and then if you have times
gate where one input captures only the
mty assignment you can just remove it
because it doesn't have any effect and
now you're left with another problem
which is these end gate these times
Gates that have only one input what I'm
going to do with them well then you can
just collapse these chains and basically
when you when pre-processing the circuit
and going down times gate with only one
input so just connect the one input back
to the directly to the times gate so
that you ensure that you do not have
times gate with only one input connected
to another times gate with only one
input so once you have done so you see
so this is not very complicated it's
just a bit tedious now we have
normalized the circuit to get rid of
these two problems empty assignments and
the empty set as an assignment this is
now guaranteeing that when traversing a
times gate we make progress so this is a
bit harder to visualize if you think of
the recursive algorithm when you get
into a times gate and the assignment
when you get into a times gate you're
going to recurse now in two inputs of
the times gate and combine the two
assignments and thanks to this
pre-processing you know that uh the
assignments captured by the left and by
the right are non-empty right they
contain variables so if you think about
the big assignment you're going to
produce in the end it must come from
something to the left and something to
the right and so the big assignment that
you output has been split between the
left and the right meaning that when you
produce an assignment with 42 variables
you you can only have seen 41 times gate
because each times gate has split the
assignment that you were producing so
this guarantees that when producing an
assignment the number of times Gates you
have traversed is linear in the size of
the assignment so now each time you see
a times gate you splitting the
assignments being produced so you're
making progress and So you you're in
good shape to get the output linear near
delay okay yes when you have that nested
Loop right so the inner loop is also
guaranteed to not take too long so you
have basically guarantee that every
subcircuit is also giving you that same
constant delay in its output size yeah I
mean in the when doing the the recursive
algorithm I'm using inductively the fact
that when I recurse on the two inputs
then they're producing the each
assignment in output linear delay in the
size of that assignment and so like
combining them I can get output linear
delay
I have to spend uh I mean I need to
concatenate them I cannot spend linear
time concatenating them so I need like
to Output the first and then the second
because otherwise it would be quadratic
but yeah
works okay so we're good still have one
problem don't if you can see what the
problem
is the problem is or Gates oh sorry
Union Gates and complicated structures
of Union gat
so I've told you when we see a times
gate we make progress when we see a
variable of course we're happy because
this is this is easy when we see an or
gate Union gate this is we could be
recursing and say I won't produce my
assign the assignments captured by that
gate okay I recurse on that gate I
recurse on that gate and so on and I
could be spending lots of time going
down in the circuit on Union Gates until
I find something that will allow me to
make
progress yes so do you have a reason why
all your Gates have to have a f name too
uh so I can enforce it for the Times
gate for the union Gates not I I could
re I could rewrite the circuit in linear
time
associativity andity of Union you could
use Union gates with very multiple fun I
could uh it it's easier I think to
present the algorithm with the fan is to
and like up in the linear time
pre-processing I can change the the I
can rewrite Union Gates so that they all
have fan in at most
two but uh okay and this is indeed using
commutativity and associativity of the
underlying sem
ring I'm sure we can talk about if the
seing is different and well okay no a
seing should be
associative I'm sorry already solve the
problem that you have here no it would
not because even if the Fanon is at
moose two which is the case in this
drawing actually I can still spend lots
of time going down uh chain of Union
Gates I the other way around using
unbounded fan uh even if the fan in is
unbounded it could still be the case
that all of the inputs are union Gates
as
well right so I what I could do is do a
transitive closure okay and this works
better indeed if the fan in is unbounded
but the problem is I don't have in
linear time preprocessing I don't have
the time to compute this transitive
closure right I really want my
pre-processing to be linear so to to
make this a bit more precise
when we get to to a union gate we want
to get to a non-union gate as quickly as
possible so we think of all the
non-union Gates having a path to that
Union gate via Union Gates and we want
to explore these and enumerate these we
want to enumerate the union of the the
captured assignments by these Gates and
we must find these efficiently if I had
quad if I have um if I had enough time
to compute the transitive closure I
could just connect all of these gates to
the to the corresponding Union Gates but
since I mean this is obviously not
possible and obvious obviously it it
doesn't have linear size I and
conditionally I'm not going to be able
to do this in linear time right yes why
can't you just collapse two modes there
two Union
con uh I might be um I cannot always do
this because I could have the these two
things could be feeding into different
Gates and so I might I might even if
this one feeds into this one there might
be some other Gates taking the product
with this one and others taking the
product with this one so I cannot just
collapse all of this anyways I need to
remember what has a path to which gate
but I cannot afford to compute the exact
set what I must compute instead is a
structure allowing me to enumerate given
the union gate what are the reachable
exits and this is this looks pretty
challenging to do in a in a general dag
but fortunately we are saved by
determinism have forgotten about
determinism determinism also guarantees
that you cannot have something like this
like a gate cannot have two different
paths to the same Union gate because
otherwise you would have duplicates so
if you think about a layer of Union
Gates like this it is not an arbitrary
dag it is what's called a multitree so
do not confuse multi trees with poly
trees this thing can still contain un
undirected Cycles a multi tree is a dag
that does not contain a diamond okay and
it so happens that we can find an
algorithm to basically process multi
trees by pushing up at least one exit of
a gate each time so that afterwards we
can explore downwards in a way that will
produce one exit each time we visit a
gate so this is not obvious it's not
very complicated I can explain to you
the Whiteboard one if you want to if you
want to ask me about it but um this can
be done and once this is done it means
the real algorithm is when you get to a
union gate you enumerate its exit with
with with constant delay and for each
exit you recurs into it okay
I think I missed something but there is
a linear bound on regardless of the
choice of exits you take there is a
upper bound that's linear that you will
reach the exit right regardless of how
yeah but I want the outputs to be
enumerated in output linear delay
meaning if I'm producing an output of
size three I must visit like some number
of gates that depends on three not the
linear number of gates in the circuit so
I cannot spend a linear time in the
circuit to produce my assignment and all
of this is about finding a way to
shortcut this so that I each time so
what this this ensures that when I get
into a union gate I can then in constant
with constant delay jump to a non-union
gate which would be either a variable or
a times gate that splits the variables
and this is going this is what gives me
my output linear delay
guarantee
okay applications of this result so I
have motivated all of this with
intentional querer evaluation but where
I is of course I don't do query
evaluation in usual database in the
usual database sense I meant monic
second queries of course over trees
which are special kinds of database so
we have a tree the database is actually
a tree uh with nodes colored from an
alphabet of possible colors my query is
written in this very practical language
of monic second order logic which
generalizes cqs uqs first order logic
allows quantification of a set you can
talk about reachable reachability
descendant in the tree whatever so for
instance this is an uninteresting MSO
query saying find me all of the pairs of
a pink node and a blue node and I want
to enumerate the results of such queries
on trees so find me all pairs of nodes
of the trees such that this query
holds and I'm measuring data complexity
so the query is fixed um just measuring
efficiency as a function of the input
tree I'm I'm hiding a non-elementary
dependency in the query of course when I
do that as usual with MSO but this is a
this is
theory and if you don't like the
non-elementary dependency in MSO in the
MSO query I will be talking about
efficient combined evaluation
data it was known before us that proved
by B and by Kaz found that we can
enumerate the answers to MSU queries on
trees with linear pre-processing and
constant delay so thanks to the Circuit
result we can provide an alternative
proof of this uh of this fact so given
an automaton representing the MSU query
okay well we can prove this via this
intermediate result saying if I have the
MSU query Express as a bottom up
deterministic Tre automaton and I have
the input Tree by doing a kind of
product of product construction I can
compute a ddn andf set circuits
capturing the results I'm interested in
this is the compilation result and then
you just invoke the enumeration
algorithm I presented to you and you get
this so This equals this times the
previous result yes what will be the of
this it will be the same size that it
takes to produce it so
automat yeah so the non-elementary
dependency in the query is hidden in the
fact that this a is very large as a
function
of this is where the problem is if you
start by giving me a small automaton
then there is no catch this is a this is
a combine this is a result in Combined
complexity
actually the circuit approach allows us
also to study efficient update support
or incremental maintenance we also have
talks about this in program uh we can
support relabeling updates to the tree
meing if the tree is changed and some
nde colors are modified we can handle
these in logarithmic time and re and
update or enumeration structure without
having to rerun the entire linear time
pre-processing so this task of
enumeration plus updates had been
studied before and this this was a new
results that we can get thanks to
circuits and this is circuits are a nice
thing for incal computation because uh
it's easy to see when you have a circuit
and I have a gate I can condition to
change this gate to be something
else okay so and or circuit computations
are bottom up so all of This lends
itself pretty well to update support we
have also claimed in 2019 that the same
was true for updates to the Trees of the
form inserting a leaf deleting a leaf
and unfortunately there's a broken
dependency problem with this result
because this result depends on another
result that turned out to be to have an
erroneous proof there is a revised
version of that proof currently under
review so hopefully we'll be soon be
able to replug a a correct proof of the
auxiliary result and get back the so
this is like coinductive result Pro so
so far what I can tell you is a
conditional type result saying assuming
there exists an algorithm with that
specification then we get
that
application
two document spanners um so this is the
context where I want to do information
extraction I have data which is text and
to a theoretician mind text is just a
special case of a tree although many
people wouldn't see it that way I have a
query which is a regular expression
again the theoretician doesn't see the
difference between a regular expression
and a montic second order
query you can sell the same result with
a completely different dis guys to a
different community that way and what
you want to get is which substrings
match the pattern so this means think
that you're crawling the web you have
lots of text and you want to find
anything that looks like an email
address so an at a word surrounded by
two spaces and containing an ad sign and
you want to upd Output efficiently the
list of all of the email addresses you
have found on the web because say you
want to warn of all of these people that
they could they could be get scammed or
or fished by a bad bad people because
their email address is available on the
internet let's
imagine the goal is to be very very
efficient in the text so Conant delay
enumeration of that stuff what's new so
this is not just a repackaging of the
previous result because now I want to
also be efficient in the pattern so have
poal time data complexity so this is not
an MSO formula this is a regular
expression which is something that I I
am told people actually use out there in
the real world I want to be polinomial
in that regular expression I do not want
to be exponential or
worse and we can show that this is
possible because uh we can enumerate the
results captured by a nondeterministic
automaton with captures which is a weird
automaton formalism that you can get in
P time from a regular expression with
captures and the pre-processing is
linear in the text and polinomial in the
aaton and the delay is constant in the
text and poal in the
automaton this is also showed using some
kind of product construction between the
um the the automaton and the text and
then applying
enumeration and uh it generalizes an
earlier results where so this had been
known before for deterministic automata
but if you're given a regular expression
you cannot efficiently convert it to a
deterministic automaton so you really
need the power of this to work with
non-deterministic automata which is nice
because it's a technically challenging
question but it works uh I would be
lying to you if I pretended that this is
done via a nice knowledge compilation
approach you could phrase that proof as
in a circuit based thing using bonded
with UOB bdds and it generalizes to
trees and then it would be using bounded
withd set dsdn andf or something it's
not uh well for the the for the for the
document spanner result is not written
in this fashion but conceptually this is
what's going on and yeah we can do the
same thing on trees so on the thing is
on trees you don't really have a
language for regexs so it doesn't really
make so much sense to talk about being
tractable in a representation of the
automaton because it's not really clear
what the representation should be but
there's no there's no
obstacle three um very quickly we have
been working on generalizing Beyond MSO
and automata to work with um annotated
grammar so you have text which is not
say source code in some programming
language you have a pattern expresses a
context free grammar with uh
Terminals and um yeah we want to find
all quoted strings in the program for
instance and then we can also do
enumeration to find all occurrences of a
pattern like this if the grammar is
unambiguous which is necessary to get a
ddn andf kind of and the pre-processing
is no longer linear in the input word
but it's cubic and we have Sub sub
classes where the the preprocessing can
be made quadratic or linear up to
assumptions in the grammar so this
improves on an earlier result that had a
a worse bound on the pre-processing and
a slightly different model of of
grammar um I think it's time for me to
conclude this sple of the the Earth
creation and again so there are other
applications to these kind of techniques
using circuits for enumerations so
Martin Munos and christinos in Chile are
also using this so they don't they don't
call it ddn andf set circuits they call
it innumerable compact sets this is a
marketing difference they see it as not
really building a circuit but
constructing a kind of data structure
that's fully persistence by adding gates
to a circuit so this is a difference in
Vision but it's really technically the
same thing that's going on and they have
en numeration results using these
inumerable complex sets for visibly
pushed down transducers on nested
documents and for automat on SLP
compressed
documents there are also results for
career evaluation so you might say I
have lied to you because I've said
career evaluation and then it turn out
only to be about this MSO stuff well if
you want to evaluate first order queries
not MSO queries
on bounded expansion databases there is
a result by tunik that uses this set
well the set circuits terminology to get
enumeration for free kind of and U if
you want to do cqs on uh and get use
these results you can also do it and
Floren will be talking about this this
afternoon and uh there's also a recent
paper by by BS and ven Smith about
enumerating homomorphisms between
structures that uses something called d
representations which is pretty related
to uh to these circuits and uses it to
get enumeration results for enumerating
homomorphisms
between one word about ranked
enumeration there is a big problem with
enumeration algorithms is that there is
no guarantee in which order they produce
the results which I think for practice
is not great we motivate enumeration by
saying oh you can get the first results
quickly and then you can ask for more
results but if the results are provided
to you in a random order that's not very
useful F think about a search engine
that would just return all of the pages
that match in in an arbitary order it
wouldn't be good so for MSO which is the
main the main thing I do the ranked
enumeration is possible with logarithmic
delay it had been shown by Pierre Pier
bis and others and our recent work is
about extending this to MSO on trees the
very high level idea for the recursive
algorithms with produce with products
and unions is that you will use priority
cues in the middle of the algorithm and
there are also works for ranked access
which is a general which is stronger
than ranked enumeration for conjunctive
queries including by by many people in
this in this program I think floron will
talk about this as well in the CQ
context so to conclude I have presented
to you how to enumerate satisfying
assignments of ddn andf set circuits
with linear preprocessing output linear
delay I have shown you how to apply this
to intentional career evaluation for Ms
on Words and on trees and also some
other applications and other things like
incremental maintenance rank
enumeration what's next um from from
most immediate to least immediate I'm
here for the rest of the program I'm
happy to talk to you about details of
any of these things or discussing
research about these questions what
about negation Gates there are no
negation Gates but if you want to do
enumeration and you get negation and you
want to remove stuff it seems to mess up
enumeration and we don't really
understand what could be done is
determinism really necessary it's of
course very useful but I I don't think
we know of lower bound saying you you
will you wouldn't be able to enumerate
if you hadn't if you hadn't
theism what about updates so handling
updates to the to the data with better
than Logan time knowing that in some
cases when you want to do incremental
maintenance of these things without
enumeration you can get down to constant
time updates or log log and
updates what about enumeration with
better than output linear delay and we
have with Mikel we have a a funny model
of enumeration by editing previous
answers on which it would make in which
it would make sense to look at this
question what about connections between
automa classes and circuit classes this
is something people program interested
in as well and yeah can we can we follow
this intentional approach to classify
enumeration tasks by looking at the
circuit classes to which we can and
compile them and try to get a better
understanding of existing enumeration
results using this this knowledge
compilation based
framework that's all I wanted to
[Applause]
say can you uniform the sample with um
linear time
um not necessarily if you can do
counting then yes so of course if you
can do counting then you can use this
for uniform sampling and if the circuit
is deterministic then you can do
it um but it's not related really to the
enumeration results because the
enumeration results also work without
determinism in some
cases and so we what I want to say is we
have the classes of circuits that are
non deterministic and which we know how
to enumerate so and we know that we
probably cannot count so I would guess
that this means there are classes where
you can enumerate but you we don't know
how to do uniform sampling because
otherwise you can just repeatedly call a
uniform sampler and then with very low
probility you'll get
collisions at the beginning yes but as
you go on in the enumeration you're
going to have more and more collisions
now
like a polog delay I
think yeah yeah
okay so I yeah I haven't done anything
like this I don't know if people have
tried to do eneration the way you
suggest yes ah okay we have a paper like
this with key where we do that and
collector Bic B time and we use like
hyper log log to maintain small
footprint and
[Music]
I'm still trying to understand how uh
you you go from a database to a circuit
so say I have a table with two rows and
two columns so is is that just a union
node and then on each side you have two
product nodes uh so you can you can see
this as
uh if your data is like
this
you can write it
as but you suggested yes I see
uh this is like the dnf version of the
data but if if the data is like this
then you could factor and you could
write it like in a factorized database
way like
this
okay thank
you um some quick
question no okay so let's thank the
speaker
[Applause]
again